un mortal operativo policial decenas de
personas murieron durante una nueva
incursión contra bandas del crimen
organizado en el complejo do alemao una
extensa área de favelas en el norte de
río de janeiro brasil toda la placa la
policía dice vago vas a morir ahora vago
vas a morir ahora pero podría ser su
hijo no podría ser su hijo un trabajador
pero la gente de la favela no tiene voz
amigo esto nunca acabará con nosotros no
tenemos voz su tables cerca de 400
miembros de los cuerpos de élite de las
policías militar y civil de este estado
brasileño entraron con vehículos
blindados y cuatro helicópteros para
desactivar a una banda dedicada al robo
de vehículos de carga y de bancos
mientras que las autoridades aseguraron
que sus unidades fueron violentamente
atacadas los pobladores denunciaron
brutalidad policial hacia los civiles y
supuestos allanamientos a casas
como la dinámica de cómo ocurrió eso lo
aclarara la investigación la policía
militar está colaborando plenamente con
estas investigaciones con información
necesaria para que podamos entender lo
que con la señora leticia cuya muerte
hemos lamentado profundamente
y es la segunda acción policial de alta
letalidad en una favela de río en los
últimos dos meses tras la ocurrida en
vila cruzeiro que dejó 25 muertos según
el proyecto monitor de violencia en 2021
murieron 1.300 65 personas a manos de
las fuerzas policiales en esta ciudad